Hannah brown and Tyler Cameron are sort
of addressing those dating rumors
on-again and off-again couple along with
their self-proclaimed
quarantine crew was back at it again on
Thursday still dancing I love the mess
around and danci no doubt this time
posting a tick tock video poking fun at
Tyler and Hannah's relationship status
doing the flip the switch challenge to
drink song not stop where the girls in
guys switch up close Tyler of course
ended up rocking Han as a black crop top
feet and her tan sweatpants joking in
the caption breaking Tyler finally got
into Hannah's pants although there was
no official clarification on their
relationship status the bachelor nation
and all the Hannah Tyler stands are
definitely rooting for the pair's
romantic reunion susima Tyler is not an
idiot
but there has been some concern over
their lack of compassion when it comes
to the corona virus outbreak there the
comb stop dealing tick tock videos with
groups of people
nopal former bachelor nick vile said
that during claudia austrie inking a
girl with no jobs instagram live on
Wednesday although Nick didn't get
specific it does seem that the 39 year
old reality star is addressing his
fellow bachelor nation alums about not
taking social distancing seriously okay
I'm bored in the house and I'm in a
house boy Nick's concern is for good
reason as the pair has been flaunting
their vacation stop quarantine by the
pool in South Florida with house since
Hannah's arrival into town last Saturday
it's been you know life-changing has
been the most amazing thing I've ever
been a part of
[Music]